SPEAKER 1: Welcome.
This video is
designed to show you
how Google Cloud certifications
can allow you to demonstrate
your skills, boost your career,
and thrive within the partner
program.
We'll review the
partner-exclusive benefits
available to help you prepare
for becoming Google Cloud
Certified.
Google Cloud is the
fastest growing cloud
with significant advantages
in big data processing
and analytics at scale.
Whether you're just beginning
your career in cloud
or have more experience
with other cloud solutions,
validating your technical
expertise by getting Google
Cloud Certified will
help you demonstrate
that you have the
critical skills
to drive business
success in today's highly
competitive market.
The Google Cloud
certification program
includes two levels of
certification-- professional
and associate.
The associate certification
is focused on the core Google
Cloud Platform technology,
and it's a good starting point
for those who are new to
cloud in general or new
to Google Cloud
Platform specifically.
The professional
certifications are
job role-based certifications
and assess advanced design
and implementation
skills developed
through hands-on experience.
These certifications are
focused on the core job
roles in cloud infrastructure,
data and machine
learning, application
development, networking,
and security.
Now that we've
covered the basics,
let's talk about the steps
and partner-exclusive
resources available to help you
prepare for your Google Cloud
certification.
Your professional experience
is the most critical part
of the preparation journey.
Use the available
exam guides to gauge
how your skills and
knowledge match up
to the job skills that will be
evaluated in the certification
exam.
We're delighted to provide you
partner access to hands-on labs
and on-demand training courses.
We also recommend
taking the practice
exams that are available
for our certifications.
These practice exams
will familiarize you
with the types of
questions you may
encounter on the
certification exam
and help you determine
your readiness
or if you need more
preparation or experience.
You can find all these
partner-specific resources
including webinars, partner
certification kickstart,
promotions, and other events
on the Google Cloud Partner
Portal.
We also recommend checking
out some additional resources
like our Google Cloud
documentation pages
or the Google Cloud
Platform YouTube
channel for videos and tutorials
on Google Cloud products
and solutions.
We encourage you to visit the
Google Cloud certification
website for more information
and take the first step
to earn your badge and become
Google Cloud Certified.
Thanks so much for watching.
We look forward
to seeing what you
accomplish with your next
Google Cloud certification.